in our exclusive interview brianna
taylor's boyfriend told us
about his struggles with the emotional
trauma of her death kenneth walker was
with taylor the night she was killed by
louisville police officers
during a narcotics raid in march now
police were investigating another man
neither walker nor taylor had a criminal
history and no ill
no illegal drugs were found in the home
walker told us his love story with
taylor began
actually on twitter we went to the
louisville home to talk to him and his
parents
who considered taylor family they say
that she brought
joy into everybody's life
kenny i want to know about brianna
taylor what was it about her that
attracted you to her
she was funny like me and i can see from
twitter she played a lot just like me
always joking
always laughing come on
these two how did you know that she was
the one for you
it was friends for a long time before
ever
evolved into any anything else
so i think that's how i knew she was the
one we was too good at being friends
but it ended up working out and
finally we was getting it together right
getting it together like you thought i
could marry you get it together
that kind of thing that was definitely
in the talks definitely had a
baby names and everything like like
cambrie oh that's kenneth and brianna
together
walker says he and taylor were
collecting their favorite items for the
family they hope
to build like this pair of mini air
jordans for the baby
they want it together looking at these
baby shoes
what do they mean to me it means it's
something that's never going to happen
walker's parents volitia and kenneth
walker jr have been supporting their son
through his grief
and want justice for brianna taylor the
woman who would have been their
daughter-in-law
i say it all the time you know as a mom
you know you want the best mate for your
children
and she just completed us she completed
the family
on the night of the police raid kenneth
says in his fear and panic
he called his mother for help before
calling 9-1-1
volicia walker rushed to the scene and
recordings released by louisville police
show
that she spoke to officers about what
her son told her
that night he called me and said
mama they kicked in the door they keep
there no i don't know what's going on
it's just one of those calls as as a mom
that we hope we never get
at one o'clock in the morning he
couldn't tell you what had happened
could he he didn't know
i didn't hear anything at first in the
background i just heard him screaming
and crying
what's your biggest concern as we sit
here today about kenneth
it's hard i'm mama i can see things
about him that he doesn't even realize
whereas when they were little kids if
you had a bump on it you could fix it
i could blow it but i can't fix this
i've only listened to that 911 call
once or twice and it took me months to
listen to it and the thing is
his whole life i've always been there to
help him or to be there for him
and i couldn't help him because he was
considered a suspect in the beginning
right and i mean you know think about it
reality is he still was suspecting their
mind
he's still their scapegoat in the chaos
that followed the death of brianna
taylor on march 13th
walker was indicted for the attempted
murder of a police officer
in may those charges were dropped
without prejudice which means the case
can be refiled in the future
for kenneth and his family it is a stark
possibility
that they never could have imagined you
know the simple lessons that we teach
them
that we hold true as parents
the lessons that we treat you know ain't
nothing good for you going on at the
streets stay at home
here you are this one time you at home
and you get in the worst trouble you've
ever been at home
at home and you did nothing wrong but do
what you were taught to do
be a man protect your family
tell the truth hey stop playing with it
it's like march 13th every day pretty
much
i never got to say bye so
that makes a big deal makes a big
difference when it first happened
you're labeled a suspect brianna's
labeled a suspect and the police officer
who was shot
is labeled a victim what do you make of
that
she usually had goals when you black and
deal with police
that's all i think of that i don't
necessarily even see this as a black
white issue it became that
after they figured it out but this is a
right and wrong issue
it don't matter if he was blue pink
purple you know white black
doesn't really matter it could have been
elderly people in there it could have
been kids it could have been anything
so it was just wrong all the way around
the board no matter who was in there
but it definitely turned into a black
and white thing when i walked out
yeah we should say that neither you or
brianna taylor had a
criminal history of violence or
drugs i guess that doesn't matter to
them you know people like to skip over
that part
where do you go from here i mean i look
at you and i just see
so much pain and rightfully so do you
have friends who are helping you
i i actually do have a therapist i
probably need to i'm gonna
i'll be talking to him a lot more yeah
but
i really don't agree with therapy but
you got to try everything to try to
be okay
[Applause]
when you hear the chance say her name
what does that mean to you when you hear
that
it means she's getting the respect that
she deserves
now that's the least that could happen
what does justice look like for you for
brianna taylor brianna taylor sitting
right here next to me
that's the only justice for me wow
none of the officers involved were
charged for brianna taylor's death both
the louisville metro police department
and attorneys for the three individual
officers involved
declined our request for interview or
comment on this case and another thing
that was really touching
when we were at her house because he
couldn't go the funeral because he was
in prison for attempted murder of a
police officer
briana taylor's mother has given him a
little urn of her ashes
and they showed us the ashes i didn't i
didn't show it on camera but just to be
able to
hold it and see it was very very i
i could physically feel that yes of
course it means a lot to him to have it
but
there's just so many inconsistencies in
this story he is such a
and he is such a compelling interview
and as we we were talking in the
break but one of the things i said to
you was this started with a warrant
yes that clearly was misguided they were
at the wrong place
and that's what i want to know how that
warrant got there yeah that's why
candice says it's not a black white
issue to him it's
right right or wrong right or wrong
issue and you understand why he reacted
the way he did because he and
this is the thing his story has never
changed from that very first night
he's been very consistent about he had
no idea what was happening and to your
point about the warrant
his his attorneys were there of course
while we were talking to him and they
they can
fill us in on how that war it came to be
and why this story does seem to have
gone awry
listen it started out playing uno and
watching a movie yeah and at the end of
the night only one person has survived
that
and now can we say there's nothing
sadder or more tragic than a pair of
baby shoes never worn
tony there were so many things it was a
very very very tough day